- Hi everyone, it's Sal
here from Khan Academy.
I am back in the walk-in closet
where Khan Academy all
began, socially distanced.
Obviously the entire
globe is going through
a very unusual crisis right
now, and as part of that crisis,
people are worried about three things.
They're worried about their health,
both physical and mental health,
they are worried about the economy,
and then they're worried
about how do we ensure
that kids can keep learning
with now nearly a billion kids
that otherwise would be in
school are now out of school
in order to protect
people from this virus.
All of us here at Khan
Academy, as a not for profit
with a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone, anywhere,
recognize that it's our duty
to step up in this crisis.
We never could have foreseen
this type of situation,
but we want to be there to
support you, support students,
parents, teachers to get
us through this situation.
We've always been working on resources
starting from pre-K with Khan Academy Kids
that covers math, reading, writing,
social/emotional learning,
all the way through
the main Khan Academy website and app
that goes from kindergarten
through the core of college,
including middle school and high school
in math, English language
arts, the sciences.
We have history, economics.
We also have official
SAT practice for you.
But as we saw the school
closures begin to happen
over the last few days
and now it's accelerating,
we realize that we need to do more,
so on top of that we
are publishing resources
for parents, for students, for teachers
to be able to understand how
to navigate the situation.
Just recently we published schedules
so that students, parents and teachers
can structure students' days,
and there's different
schedules for students
of different age groups.
And we are doing daily live streams
so that in this time of social distancing,
we all can feel connected and make sure
that we're there to support each other.
The team here at Khan
Academy is very focused
on making sure we can support
you all through this crisis.
We're seeing the server load increase,
and so the engineering
team is reassuring me
that we think we have it.
We're also exploring other
ways that we can support you,
and we're looking at ways that we can get
more help for folks, things like that.
I will remind folks that
we are not for profit.
Even before this crisis, we were operating
at a bit of a deficit, and
so if you're in the position,
especially as our demands on our server
and our costs are going
up as people use us more,
if you are in a position, I
hope you could think about
supporting us philanthropically.
I want to really thank Bank of America.
Just over this past
weekend they stepped up.
They realized that our
costs were going up,
that we had to have a
better response effort,
so they have helped us
there, but we need more help.
For any of you all out
there who are in a position,
whether individual or corporation,
if you're finding use out of
the resources we're providing,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
It will allow us to support
the nation and the world
as we go through this very,
very unusual crisis together.
Last but not least, I just want to say
as one human being talking to another,
this is a new frontier for all of us,
but I've been very
heartened by the humanity
that I'm seeing in everyone.
Everyone is just trying
to help everyone else
as a human being, and I'm confident
that if we just do the next right thing,
one step after another, that
we're all going to be able
to get each other through this situation.
Thank you.